quebec es la provincia canadiense con
más casos de vida del mono reportados
con al menos 70 contagios mientras que
las otras provincias habían confirmado
sólo 6 casos este viernes las
autoridades de quebec han empezado a
ofrecer vacunas para gente con alto
riesgo de contraer la enfermedad como
los que han estado en contacto con un
caso confirmado en los últimos 14 días
ahora que me he vacunado me siento
bastante seguro bueno más seguro y
confiado de que estoy haciendo mi parte
en esta lucha contra la viruela del mono
aunque todavía tengo que esperar unos
días de 7 a 10 antes de que mi sistema y
uno lógico esté preparado para la
batalla
la viruela del mono es una enfermedad
que circula en el oeste de áfrica desde
1980 sin embargo en las últimas semanas
27 países que normalmente no están
afectados reportaron más de 700 casos
especialmente en europa y norteamérica
algo que nunca había pasado hasta ahora
investigue se usaron las investigaciones
están en curso pero la repentina
aparición de la viruela
en muchos países al mismo tiempo sugiere
que puede haber habido una transmisión
no detectada durante algún tiempo los
síntomas generalmente son fiebre y
erupción cutánea en la cara y otras
partes del cuerpo
la transmisión interhumana se produce
entre personas que tienen contactos
físicos estrechos con casos sintomáticos
hasta ahora ningún caso de muerte se ha
reportado en países fuera de áfrica y
lado ms aseguró que el riesgo general
para la salud es bajo